13 of the total Manpower of their own
Navy was devoted to stopping
uh slave ships leaving West Africa for
the Americas just stopping that quite
apart from stopping slavery elsewhere
slavery and trading slaves
was a universal Institution
almost from the dawn of time
um so long before Europeans got into it
and the Portuguese were the first in the
1440s
um in terms of of trading in Africans
although there was slavery I mean
Bristol was a slave market in in the in
the medieval period Irish slaves being
traded to to Norsemen who then took them
down the Volga to the Black Sea so
there's lots of of slave trading
around Europe but also uh Africans were
involved in in trading other Africans as
slaves to the Romans and then and then
to the Muslim Arabs
um the Comanche
the Indian the amerindian people who uh
dwelt in the
Southwest of what's now the United
States
um according to one eminent historian uh
ran a vast slave economy in the 1700s
and then the um um in the 1700s in
Jamaica when when slaves escaped from
the plantations and went into the
forested interior the mountains interior
of Jamaica they're called maroons
they often held slate of their own and I
was in I was in uh
Raleigh North Carolina in January
visiting my my wife's family
there and I went to the Museum of the
history of North Carolina
which told me that
um on the eve of the American Civil War
in 1860
there were thirty thousand freed slaves
in the state of North Carolina some of
whom owned slaves of their own and my
point is we have to
accept the fact that for many people
even former slaves owning slaves was
acceptable or normal
and and even if you um you might well uh
um if you're in the 18th century 9th
century you might well object to cruel
and inhuman forms of slavery
and yet still think that slavery was a
kind of a fact of life
so we just have to accept that and get
get our heads around it it doesn't
necessarily mean that everyone until us
was morally corrupt and and and uh um
morally insensitive
um
so that's that's that's one thing
so there's nothing there was nothing
exceptional about the British
involvement and slavery in the
70s and 18th centuries
uh what was exceptional and
extraordinary was that toward the end of
the 18th century
um partly because of Enlightenment views
mainly because of
Christian views
um the idea that
owning other human beings as property
began to be questioned on principle
and so in 18 1787 you get the the
creation of the Society of the abolition
of slavery in England
um I think Denmark was the first state
in Europe to abolish the slave trade
within its limited territories
um Britain followed uh three years later
you know seven
uh and then 1833 the Empire abolished
slavery as an institution within its
territories so so let me just make this
clear because
um at the moment
in recent years we've been encouraged in
Britain to to uh look again at the
horrors of slavery in which our
ancestors were involved for 150 200
years
as if nothing had changed
uh so so the the the the fact that
Britain was among the first states in
the history of the world
to abolish the slave trade and then to
abolish slavery and it then led the
world in suppressing both of those as I
said from Brazil across Africa to
Malaysia that was extraordinary no other
state had done that before
no other states had done that before
certainly not in Africa certainly not in
Asia nor in among the indigenous peoples
of North America that was extraordinary
and and we carried on doing that
for until the end of the empire in the
1960s and in 1820s and 30s the slavery
trade Department in the British foreign
office was the largest unit
um and in the 1830s about 40s
thereabouts 13 of the total Manpower of
their own Navy was devoted
to um into in to stopping
uh slave ships leaving West Africa for
the Americas
uh just stopping that quite apart from
stopping slavery elsewhere
um so I do think we need to remember the
the the fact that we couldn't undo what
we've done for 200 years worth of of of
enslaving all we could do was stop it
and then try and stop it elsewhere
thank you
foreign